فريد عدد مذهل من الجرحى في
هذا الهجوم الروسي العشوائي الآخر
على منطقة مدنية في
وسط تشيرنوبي.
قال مسؤولون محليون في مقهى تيراسيز في باركس، إنهم
عائدين من مهرجان ديني أرثوذكسي،
سقط الصاروخ بالقرب من
مركز معارض كان مغلقًا
على ما يبدو  في ذلك الوقت ولكن
قبل ساعتين من ذلك، تم
الإعلان عن اجتماع على فيسبوك حول تكنولوجيا الطائرات بدون طيار
سواء كان ذلك مرتبطًا عن بعد
بهذا الهجوم الروسي، لا
نعرف، لكنه بالتأكيد مثال آخر
على الطريقة الفادحة التي تطلق بها روسيا
صواريخها على مناطق مدنية مما تسبب في
ذهول  يبدو أن عدد القتلى في هذا
اليوم الهادئ من عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في مدينة مزدحمة هو
بمثابة تذكير آخر لما
قد يقوله الأوكرانيون وهو مدى حاجتهم الملحة إلى
دفاعات جوية أفضل مثل تكنولوجيا F-16
التي يبدو أنها
في متناول أيديهم قليلاً وإن كانت
متأخرة للغاية.  لقد سمعنا من الدنمارك أحد
الحلفاء الأوروبيين للولايات المتحدة
الذي وافق على تدريب الطيارين الأوكرانيين
على قيادة تلك الطائرات وعلى
التكنولوجيا الخاصة بهم، وقد يبدأون هذا
التدريب في غضون الـ 12 يومًا القادمة،
وهذا مهم الآن لأنه قد يبدأ
الجدول الزمني  الآن، عندما يتمكن
الأوكرانيون من البدء في تحليق طائرات F-16
في السماء، تدعم الولايات المتحدة هذا
سيدعم إمداد
أوكرانيا بالطائرات، لكن هذا قد يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً في
العام المقبل وتقول القوات الأوكرانية الآن بشكل عاجل
إنها بحاجة إلى نوع من
الدعم الجوي في  هجومهم المضاد على
الجبهة الجنوبية لأنهم
يتعرضون للضرب من قبل الطائرات الروسية في
كثير من الأحيان كل ساعة
بمتفجرات قوية غير عادية ولكن
تذكير آخر بالطبيعة العشوائية
للهجمات الروسية ضد
المدنيين في هذا الهجوم المروع في
ألمانيا.